Speaker 1: Hey, I want to kind of go through
a sampling of the nutty stuff that happened
over this weekend with Republicans.
None of these clips that I'm going to play
for you is sort of worthy of its own story,
but sometimes it's just stunning how much
absurdity the American Right gets into over
a 48 hour weekend that I want to just give
you like a little bit of a tour through the
bonkers universe of the American Right.
So let's just look at a couple of things real
quick.
Melania Trump was given an award by the log
cabin Republicans called the Spirit of Lincoln
Award, and Melania gave a speech with a teleprompter.
Of course, even though Trump and the right
hates teleprompters when Obama uses them,
and it's just all very weird.
Speaker 3: I empathize with the situation
and creating awareness of these and other
important issues, such as foster care sickle
cell.
Social, emotional learning,
Speaker 5: fitness and neonatal absence.
Speaker 1: So just everything is so weird,
it's hard to even know what the hell is going
on with these strange awards that they hand
each other.
So that was Melania.
Roger Stone, former guest on this show.
Convicted.
Pardoned.
OK.
You know Roger Stone.
Roger Stone appeared on Alex Jones Infowars
and said, Infowars is what you can trust for
the truth.
Speaker 3: Infowars is a beacon of freedom.
That's why Infowars can always be counted
on or the truth.
You can always go to Infowars.com and find
out what is really going on.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, if you're curious about Roger Stone,
check out the time I interviewed him.
The big kind of weird story with that was
up until about 30 seconds before the interview.
You could hear him in the background trying
to get out of the interview, and then he sat
down and did the interview.
Just an odd guy.
And now this connection between I mean, this
guy was a Trump really a Trump is as close
to a friend as Trump ever had.
Now, just openly saying Infowars is the source
that you have to trust.
Senator Josh Hawley, one of the insiders of
the Jan. six insurrection, did a very strange
sit down interview with Axios.
And he went on a rant about the left attacking
manhood, and he criticized video games and
porn.
Just strange.
Take a look.
What's a man
Speaker 3: to paint a picture?
What's a man?
And, well, a man as a father, a man as a husband,
a man, as somebody who takes responsibility,
as conservatives.
We've got to call them back to responsibility.
We've got to say that spending your time not
working and we have more and more men who
are not working, spending your time on video
games, spending your time watching porn online
while doing nothing is not good for you, your
family or this country.
So viewers watching this and they're thinking
really, what the Liberals are doing are going
to push me to watch porn hub more or play
Donkey Kong more.
Do you mean that?
Literally.
Well, what I mean, literally is that I think
the liberal attack, the left wing attack on
manhood says to men, you're part of the problem.
It says that your your masculinity is inherently
problematic.
It's inherently oppressive.
Speaker 1: What's your what a weird interview
and continued right wing obsession with these
caricatures of what I guess they see as the
alpha male and the beta male?
And a very unusual rant.
I guess I'm struggling to even find the words
for it, for a sitting senator to go on.
But video games and porn, that's better in
the mind, I guess, of what Josh Hawley sees
as manhood.
Many anti-mask and anti-vax protests continuing
over the weekend, not just in the United States,
but in other countries, as we will soon see.
Here's one from the U.S..
Here is a picture of just one woman holding
a sign that says masks are child abuse, which
they're not.
Masks are physical and psychological abuse,
but psychological is misspelled on this woman's
mask, so that's something in a completely.
I know I use this term last week in another
one of these Kafka esque moments, here is
Cancun Cruz Republican Senator Ted Cruz attacking
John Kerry for flying to the climate conference
last week on a private jet.
And he points out, none of us have private
jets.
And then someone says, Actually, Ted, Rob
Portman does have a private jet.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: John Kerry has a private jet that
has flown dozens of times this past year all
around the country.
I don't know about you, but I don't have a
private jet.
I don't believe any of the people on this
stage have their own private jet.
Portman does.
Speaker 1: So one of the issues with making
this personal is you might have someone up
on the stage where the personal makes you
look like a hypocrite.
And of course, the bigger issue is how much
should we be talking about private jet use
in thinking about climate?
And as I talked about last week.
The people that have the private jets are
going to keep having the private jets.
Let's get them off of fossil fuels and into
renewables.
That would be my preference.
And of course, the vast majority of carbon
emissions are not coming from aviation at
all.
Never mind from private jets.
I mentioned it last week.
And then here's an Australian anti-mask anti-vax
guy who's listing all of the things he doesn't
do.
And hilariously, he says he doesn't Satan's
eyes his hands instead of sanitize it.
Satanist, this is wild.
Speaker 3: I'm 60 years old.
I joke socially distance.
I never wore a mask during the whole lockdown.
I always go to the supermarket as much as
I like.
I don't sterilize my hands or say to myself.
I just live normally and naturally, just like
I've always done.
At such a time, like anybody else, I might
get ill, and if I do, I go to bed.
I have some honey and lemon team and I sweat
it out and then I recover.
This is the way everyone should live.
And I'm not against medicine.
I think medicine is taken too far.
We have so much trust us.
Speaker 1: Yes, the Satan ization of hands,
that's really something else.
So while the weekend in right wing La La Land,
it's more scary than funny, you know, individually
we might look at a clip and we might say,
Oh, that actually is pretty funny, and we
would be right to say it's funny.
But the big picture is there is an entire
movement, not just in the United States, but
globally.
To some degree, we've seen it in Europe, we
see it in Australia, et cetera.
Certainly here in the U.S., an entire movement
based on not just ignorance, but pride in
ignorance, pride in unthinking pride, in rejecting
empiricism and science.
And that's a really, really bad thing